this is the Minimoog off which I have
developed for an image and heat and P
Maroney
it's a children's gesture controlled
midi instrument and basically it makes
really cool bleeps and bloops and when
you program it to when on shake on tilts
on upside down zon 3G on freefall they
sew it themselves they wire it
themselves they coded themselves and
then they play it there's a really
simple version of a much more
complicated piece of technology and
called the MooMoo glove which is very
cool MIDI instrument that has all sorts
of things in it accelerometers it's got
flex sensors it's got really it's quite
so in embedded wireless network you know
it's it's really made for concert level
use I was really inspired by that
technology so I've been working with
Imogen to create a really stripped-down
version of that which essentially just
uses an accelerometer to know where it
is it's based on a micro bit which is a
really cheap little microcontroller used
primarily in schools it's programmable
in micro Python but you can also use
block code which makes it great for
beginners or people who don't really get
on with text-based coding and it also
means that because you can use block
codes you can take it down to probably
around seven and age seven can can do
these fine it's got some little onboard
funky LEDs it's got an accelerometer
it's got a magnetometer
it's got ble sorry bluetooth it's got a
radio which I absolutely love the radio
functionality is really good it's only
got a few little pins but it does the
job it's a really nice introduction I
actually use this even at university
level and I'm teaching electronics just
for a rapid prototyping exercise because
you can get something up and running on
this much quicker than you can on a more
complicated board like Arduino and any
other microcontroller of your twist
great little piece of gear really cheap
really sturdy you can throw them across
the room they survived pretty much I
think I've abused it I've even washed
one it's come out all right it's an
amazing child-friendly microcontroller /
Hallam friendly microcontroller and
anyway so I've based it on this because
it's a really nice cheap piece of
it's that you're able to then reuse and
reprogramming your own different ways
the early bits of code just use the
accelerometer functionality but you can
use anything really and it's just I find
it easier to just pick one input and one
output and when you're first introducing
microcontrollers so the input obviously
is the accelerometer so knows where it
is one of these accesses and the output
is find so this is something that my
design with P Maroney this is the
world's first I think so a ball speaker
I say this is a and this is a really
cute little chip too and I've got one
off here this is one of the prototypes
with a very nice matte finish and you
can see it's got just power and grind
and crocodile clip and sewing friendly
things and then on the back flip it over
and we got here it's basically just a
little speaker it works really nicely
and the design is really cute as well
and and I got to press go on the
pick-and-place machine which was a
personal goal I've had and one kids who
made it into a sign defect glove so you
punch forwards like you and I had one
kid which was really funny just run up
to me say hey can it tell if it's in
freefall I'm like yeah yeah I could tell
that it's like like for example if you
jumped off a building I was like yep
yeah but you can tell that and this
little smile spread across his face me
runs back to his table he comes back
later drops a glove off of an off of a
table and it starts playing the funeral
march has made the most macabre piece of
technology so that's the simple version
but there's also which which is very
simple it just does like kind of square
wave based music so very chips uni very
like old-school kind of Sega but you can
do something stuff which is much more
complicated with it so they said there's
a range of different sensors onboard
there's a piece of software called lever
which takes sensor data and translates
it into MIDI files which will then talk
to Garrett band or Ableton Live which is
what I'm using for my music production
so I'm able to not just control
electronic music but I'm then also able
to patch through to MIDI instruments for
example this
it's triggered by gesture coming from
this so I've got three three stages to
it so I've got my gesture here which is
going into my computer using bluetooth
and it then converts it into a MIDI file
which is readable by GarageBand Ableton
Live or whatever and I can trigger
external instruments through that as
well so whether that's something like
this or a drum beat or some kind of
amazing vocal looks with it as well
that's really that's a really fun thing
to do but that's a lot more complicated
but it but those are kind of things that
you can actually use in performance so
you know it's it's it's from the basic
chiptune glove and all the way up to
actual music making on stage so
basically I've made a little page as I
sewn on and all we've got is ground
power and data so I've been just using
pin zero but they can use whatever one
they want and that just corresponds down
here grant 3v and pin zero the crocodile
clips we more elegant and the real thing
let me just pair it up so this is
normally Wireless and I'm only using a
USB cable because I don't have any
actual and batteries so what happens
halfway to a festival I think so this
code was actually written by an 11 year
old girl and when I gave her this I just
give her one instruction which was to
make a bow ding and then she just ran
with it and she made a cold choreography
so basically it's a Taylor Swift song so
who we are
and then she does indeed shake it off
but then I got this other one to do this
as well it's my familiar with that we
can control tempo you can control the
notes obviously you can pre-program them
or you can have them directly respond to
where your arm is in space you can have
different things playing when you point
north people get it really easily and
they just want to have a go everyone's
got a song they want to make or a sign
of fact they want to do you and you know
I don't need to tell people what to
create with these kind of things I think
they're fairly intuitive so I just enjoy
watching it speed isn't an issue on that
bothers a lot of people number one
YouTube comment was too slow but you
know if you don't understand real
physics of stuff it's pretty much for
shows now I think I actually wrote a
program that converts MIDI files into
SVG's then I can load the SVG into the
laser cutter software and because